he says his daughter was his life the
poland belarus border isn't the only
route and desperate iraqis are taking
yusuf habib's daughter died as she tried
to get from turkey to italy in a
smuggler's boat in early november but
the vessel capsized killing her the pain
is still raw
liver
i tried to prevent her from going but it
did not work she wanted help for her
daughter who suffered from ill health so
she decided to travel with her husband
she didn't make it her husband and my
granddaughter survived they are back
here my granddaughter is still sick
ibrahim is a human rights lawyer he says
the blame lies with local government for
not providing opportunities for people
it's a shame to see our youth suffering
on the borders of belarus and poland
leaving their wealthy country but
because of corruption and injustice our
youth have to leave the country they
have no opportunities here our
politicians are the ones to blame
you don't have to go far in a bill to
find young people desperate to leave
jihad is a university graduate yet the
only work he can find is a low-paying
clerical job outside the local court
life is so hard here i'm ready to leave
the country and sell everything i own
and pay smugglers just to leave for
another country everything is corrupt
here and they aren't sharing the wealth
of the nation
iraq is beginning repatriation flights
from belarus on the 18th of november but
even if that route is closed there are
still plenty of people who'll find any
way necessary to get out no matter what
the cost no matter what the success rate
and no matter how dangerous it is imran
khan al jazeera erbil